good morning hank it's tuesday i did it
i have signed my name
250 000 times in fact on the 250
thousandth time
i wrote a review of signing your name
250 000 times
and now i have packed up 78 boxes of
signed sheets that will be bound into
copies of the anthropocene reviewed book
when they go to the printer in virginia
and it is over by the way those 250
000 sheets in total weigh over 2 200
pounds so it's actually not an
exaggeration for me
to say that i've signed a ton of sheets
over the last few months
so as i signed every night for the last
i don't know like 40 or 50 nights sarah
repeatedly said
this is the last time right and every
time i've been like yes
definitely i mean my hand is not as
young as it used to be and also signing
250 000 times has brought into sharp
focus the fact that there is a limit to
how many times you can sign your name
while also being like
a parent and having a job and so on i
mean at times the hours of signing have
passed in a kind of
mesmerized flow state contentness which
i have really needed of late but at
other times with my hand cramping and
especially with deadlines looming i've
been
frustrated and overwhelmed now to be
clear i am absurdly lucky to be in a
position to sign my name 250
000 times but still it was a little
stressful and what i did to distract
myself especially over the last 10 days
or so was daydream about where each book
might end up
like maybe one will go to ocala florida
where i saw haley's comet with my dad in
maybe a couple will go to my old high
school campus maybe there will even be
one in alliance nebraska home of
carhenge an exact replica of stonehenge
built out of
junked cars i write about all these
things in the book by the way but of
course most of them will go to places
i've never seen and will never see
and there's something so lovely to me
about that a book going on adventures
its author can't imagine
and that's been so nice to think about
anyway as i was packing up the boxes
yesterday sarah again said
this is the last time right and i was
like uh yeah i mean it's definitely the
last time i attempt a six-figure number
of
signatures i can't quite close the door
hank even now i find myself waffling not
least because if i never
sign in bulk again i may never have
occasion to use my beloved electro jog
again
i mean i don't want to overstate it but
the electro jog really is the greatest
piece of machinery ever created in all
of human history i mean just look at
this beauty do its jogging
the electro jog is here to remind us
that it is possible for perfection to
emerge from disorder
you know come to think of it hank i kind
of wish i fit into the electro jog like
i could really stand to be
electro-jogged right
now anyway i don't think i'll ever sign
my name 250 000 times again but
i do want to get some work for the
electro jog so hopefully the
anthropocene reviewed will not be my
last book
hank as you know but some people
watching this may not i have had a very
rough period as i worked on finishing
this book even by the standards of this
long 14-month year
most of this has been because of things
that are more important than books
health of family trying to manage my
brain disorder and so on but a little
bit of it has been the book today is the
last day i can make even the smallest
changes to it and that's always a
strange feeling for me
starting tomorrow it isn't really my
book anymore it's in the hands of the
people in virginia who will print the
books and then
on may 18th it will belong as it should
to its readers
i can't bear to reread my stuff after it
comes out so i know that today i am
reading it for the last time now the
book is finished and has been for some
time at this point it's just me futzing
over commas and rearranging sentences
i've rearranged 50 times over the last
three years but there's such pleasure in
that for me in making and remaking the
million little choices that together
form a book and now it's about to be
sealed and to become whatever it's gonna
be
for however long it's gonna be and i'm
about to take a three-day nap or at
least a one-day nap i had to put on my
vision board don't sign
name just a as a helpful reminder hank
i'll see you on friday